donc c'est une Espagnole dit ouverte à
mon avis j'ai pas tous les noms
d'espagnol mais on avait on a déjà vu
cette ouverture notamment dans la partie
Hikaru contre karowana au candidat FCO
puis on prend là ça va reprendre du
cheval mais c'était pas cette variante
c'est pas la variante où il y a le foie
F2 égalité matérielle donc on va déjà
compter ça
les Noirs ils ont quatre contre trois
eldam le pion des 5 ça peut être une
force ou une faiblesse dans la position
là ça a encore la théorie hein ça joue
très vite
les blancs ils ont
en fait les Noirs ils ont un pion
central et contrôle mieux le centre mais
d'un autre côté ils ont pas beaucoup de
socle pour leur pièce on sent la colonne
qui peut être fragile pour ça que le fou
c'est décalé et globalement sans
l'option F7 le rock peut devenir faible
aussi donc il y a ces deux choses là qui
peuvent être en faveur de Maxime après
séviant il a il a le contrôle du centre
avec le pion dessin et il a peut-être de
l'activité le long de la colonne F après
un coup comme fou c'est 5 admettons
cavalier 4 il peut essayer d'utiliser le
socle en E4 conféré par le pion des 5
pour attaquer à la loi donc est-ce que
Maxime est mieux franchement j'en sais
rien est-ce que la position est jouable
et donne des perspectives aux blancs oui
clairement après la position donne aussi
des perspectives au noir donc on est sur
une position compliquée ça me fait bien
c'est un joueur américain il doit
maintenant avoir un peu plus d'une
vingtaine d'années depuis le temps qu'on
le voit sur le circuit mais il a fait
partie des jeunes joueurs extrêmement
talentueux il a 21 ans actuellement il
est à 26 84 il a perdu quelques points
après il fait pas une carrière de joueur
professionnel fait partie un peu de ses
joueurs américains
qui perce pas jusqu'au bout quoi au
final et au classement mondial du coup
il est 54e ça me séviant mais comme je
vous disais il joue plus trop en longue
c'est plutôt un joueur de rapide et en
rapide je le mettrai plutôt aux
alentours de la 30e place mondiale
très très très bon blitzer joueur
réellement dangereux qui va poser
beaucoup plus de problèmes à Maxime qui
tournent saga contre qui Maxime était
vraiment facile et ça se sent dans
l'attitude de Maxime qui qui l'a semble
nettement plus concentré
c'est du 15 + 2 c'est une cadence qui
convient relativement bien à Maxime là
je pense que la question qui se pose
c'est bien c'est des quatre en fait
puis on prend cavalier prend faut prend
peut-être prendre F3 prendre F3 disons
et prendre des quatre genre ça c'est
clairement une question visuellement je
serais bien rentré dedans avec les Noirs
mais ça peut être très dangereux sur le
rock genre tout rade1 et est-ce que tu
peux aller calculer si B2 marche ok là
l'ordi trouver un truc extraordinaire
vous prend H7 que Maxime va trouver s'il
est en cette position sur cavalier prend
il y a Dame des cinq dames français 5 et
sur roi prend il y a dame F5 dame
français 5
mais après quand bien même ici ce serait
pas clair qui défend F2 en plus
ce serait pas fini mais les noirs sont
moins bien le roi est trop épelé ici il
manque les puntos devant et ça peut ça
peut aller très vite donc ça c'est une
variante en fait on peut arriver à dames
en B2
regardez des coups je sais pas moi comme
tout eux deux dire je fais dames C3 tour
des trois Damas et ça va tenir donc il a
pris trois cavaliers prend le 3 il va
probablement jouer fois H5 et full B3
mais ça va gagner le pion pour Maxime je
sais pas trop ce qu'il prévoit de faire
ses vieux il a réfléchi relativement
longtemps
et Maxime peut peut-être éventuellement
aller taper ce pion des cinq en force
Maxime là qui hésite entre reprendre en
C3 ou prendre en G4 en premier car il
est rangé quatre est quand même
intéressant ouais c'est ce que j'étais
en train de me dire parce que ça vient
me prendre le fou et le fou va avoir la
liberté de taper sur deux diagonales et
il peut faire des allers-retours sur
l'une ou l'autre
ça fait mal là quand ça fait des
allers-retours rapides comme ça
ça peut mettre ça me séviant ou supplice
bah ce pion dessin qu'en fait ça peut
vraiment devenir une faiblesse on peut
aussi parfois jouer à 5 et aller taper
avec la dame en D3 en A6 et en et en H7
ni fait Dame des trois d'ailleurs
immédiatement fait un petit clin d'oeil
au Punto
je vois bien sévi en mettre le Cavaillon
F6
mais ça va enchaîner un kg 6 tour D1 ça
arrive de partout à côté côté français
commence par G6 donc il s'affaiblit
encore un peu plus le roi il était déjà
fait sur case blanc de par l'absence du
pion F7 maintenant il est faible aussi
sur case noire bon il a pas joué G5
tourra D1 ça vient taper le pion des 5
sur tout rat D8 il y a dame prend à 6
déjà c'est un château de cartes là la
position de Sam Sevian allez il va
devoir faire cavalier F6 pour amener une
pièce en défense quand même
c'est ce qui joue et la maxime va
pouvoir aller faire parler peut-être le
pion h il aurait pas dû laisser se
[ __ ] case blanche ça me sévit mais la
position était réellement difficile à
jouer mais le fou en B3 là on imagine
que Maxime va enchaîner par cavalier 5
pour éventuellement faire cavalier aussi
toucher la tour et la chasser
ces quatre aussi possible aussi possible
moi je partirai plus sur cavalier G5 et
une faiblesse je vais pas très envie de
que les Noirs s'en débarrassent après
ces quatre ça a l'air aussi extrêmement
fort sur pion prend il y a dame prend sa
touche ces 4 D4 me gênera un petit peu
cavalier j'ai 5 qui regarde peut-être
tourbé 8 qui pourchasser le fou mais bon
au pire juste x 2
il fait ces quatre alors il a dû trouver
un truc qui gagne sur des quatre que
j'ai raté après ça doit probablement
gagner parce que des quatre on peut même
faire ces cinq rois bouger car rédiger 5
ouais bon
c'est trop en fait il y a trop de pièces
qui conversent sur le roi ça me sévère à
une position
désespérée Maxime qui fait vraiment
parler la poudre de poudre ispaking
comme comme disent les Anglo-Saxons sur
leur live donc on imagine peut-être un
cavalier à 5 alors comme autre idée
défensive
avec l'idée d'essayer de supprimer ce
fou pour un peu respirer niveau roi
d'ailleurs qui a valait à 5 x 2 on
menace peut-être dame C3 double attaque
qui est assez rare de pouvoir double
attaquer des chevaux comme ça sans qu'il
puisse se protéger voilà non ça c'est
terrible
ça sent qu'il avait même pas envie de
venir à la Game c'est trop fort en face
il a l'air désespéré c'est trois
cavalier prend dame prend M6 ça a
vraiment l'air d'être le coup facile
pour se retrouver avec un pion de plus
mais bravo assez bien qui trouve la
possibilité qui donne la possibilité à
Maxime de se tromper donc ça c'est
réellement bien joué et dames ces trois
jouets évidemment trop facile
et d'un point F6 et il menace maintenant
des immédiatement tout recettes à MG7
mat et surtout au 8 il va simplement
pouvoir encaisser un premier Punto
et il va garder la taque et aussi ce
pion à 6 qui va rester en ligne de mire
pour pour le joueur français avec aussi
du H4 H5 qui peut partir qui est vite le
match du couloir et qui donne de
l'espace à l'elroit et de l'attaque au
blanc plus qu'une minute 20 pour Sam
c'est bien allez trouve au moins un coup
de défense histoire de nous faire un peu
vibrer Sam tu aurais 8 il essaye donc on
prend des 5 c'est déjà un pion de plus
pour Maxime ce cavalier mal placé la
tour mal placé le pion mal placé et les
blancs qui vont jaillir ils tentent
d'âme prend à 4 OH il se dit en fait que
s'il a un pion moi même les finales sont
perdantes et l'idée de prendre un punto
ici c'est que au moins si on survit on
n'est pas perdant
mais bon tu vas pas survivre cavalier 5
bloque les cases de retrait de la dame
on menace déjà du dame F7 roi S8 et
suivant où sera la dame il peut y avoir
des cavaliers G6 on reprend 8
il va peut-être tenter un cavalier c'est
5 mais ça devrait pas durer très
longtemps notamment déjà juste la même
fête de mc7 qui fait
qui refait pion de plus avec le pion des
qui avance
il fait cavalier des 4 est-ce qu'on a un
coup comme cavalier G4 presque mais
cavaliers G4 il y a cavalier 2 ok G4 sa
menace maintenant mais qui a léger 4
cavaluer deux te reprend au 2 il y a
dame prend D1 qui fait mat donc c'est un
petit subterfuge pour tenir la même
cette dame C7 c'est le coup facile
il va faire dame français 7
donc
[Musique]
c'est pions de plus c'est lattaque il y
a tout en fait dans là il peut faire
juste dame B7 cavaliers F7 cavalier 6
menace cavalier
il peut aussi faire damasuta B6 pour
dame F6 il va y avoir quoi cavalier C3
j'imagine mais qui a essayé trois il y a
Dame des 4 il y aura plus cavalier de
retour il y aura tu reprends le 2
il fait tour et fuite
menace rien absolument rien et peut-être
qu'il faut faire juste des six pour 17
c'est ce qui fait
c'est trop facile en fait des 6 des 7
des Français 8 et maintenant dames F6
dame 6 dames C8 facile ça doit être la
manière la plus facile de gagner mais
Maxime concentré
jusqu'au bout il vérifie qu'il y ait pas
de magouille cavalief de roi G1 et il a
dû vouloir vérifier qui est pas un dame
Descartes elle a juste Dame des 7 échec
professionnel
échange les dames et termine la partie
bon ça fait un zéro pour Max il a fait
des quatre ça me séviant on va voir ce
que Maxime joue et ce qui décide de
jouer un gambidame accepter ou est-ce
qu'il joue la greenfeld
ça part pour une fête côté Maxime
là il va pas faire la Turbo nulle
évidemment
il y a les pions C3 et des 4 donc ils
sont fragiles là ça doit être c'est
propre prise d'amas 5 échec je crois et
peut-être aussi qui existent on fait
confiance à Maxime qui est le meilleur
spécialiste de greenfeldomonde et ça
devrait il fait Damas 5 alors ça va
probablement être rock côté
séviant et sur dame prend ces trois
peut-être des 5 donc ouais dame C3 il
est pas comestible il y a tourcéen et du
coup la dame qui a pas gagné de tempo
sur échec attention Maxime on sait qu'il
a tendance quand c'est un peu trop
facile à légèrement lever le pied il va
pas falloir jouer trop facile on va se
mettre côté blanc après c'est sympa
aussi de se mettre côté blanc pour voir
les positions de l'autre côté je pense
qu'il réfléchit à des cinq fous prend
ces trois tours C1 tu donnes un pion
mais tu tapes ici tu tapes là tu gagnes
du développement et là tu menaces déjà
quelque chose comme dame B3 puis on
prend ses 6 puisque tu gagneras un temps
sur le fou et sur foug7 il y a tout
reprend ses 5 peut-être
Maxime jouerait ça est entré de la
défendre mais ça tu sais avec les Blancs
que tu es mieux
donc des cinq Maxime va pas pouvoir
aller croquer le pion et sur cavaluer 5
on peut peut-être échanger faut prendre
et même un coup comme tour B1 tapis si
tu laisses le pion C3 mais tu veux aller
jouer pour F4 F5 F4 5 et le jeu a le
droit ça ça semble dangereux
il fait fout des deux bon fout des deux
c'est trop en fait trop mou comme coup
ah c'est bien qui prend pas sa chance
pas assez dynamique c'est pas assez
dynamique comme coup il avait
l'opportunité vraiment de d'essayer de
gagner un temps et profiter que Maxime
et pas fait CD d'amassin échec pour
essayer d'aller gagner un tempo sur sur
la position logique bon les coups ça
peut être aussi ça peut être dame C7
pour sortir de ce vis-à-vis à la con là
B6 j'y crois pas j'ai l'impression qu'on
va se prendre des cinq C4 ou un truc
comme ça mais bon B6 j'aime pas du tout
la dame est dans un coin là elle revient
plus après mais après moi joueur de
scandinave j'ai envie de mettre la dame
en C7 j'aurais dame c'est ça ici je
pense il fait aussi ouais c'était
l'autre coup après j'ai du mal à évaluer
un truc pareil
genre ça qu'est-ce que ça vaut j'ai
l'impression qu'on a plus de cases
noires et qu'on a plus de pièces en
défense je pense qu'après C4 D5 on peut
pas aller prendre la cale et Maxime sur
C4 d'amassis des 5 va jouer cavalier des
4 qui prend des 4 il faut prendre des
quatre mais fais attention même un coup
comme fouet 3 ici c'est chiant parce que
vous prend un dame prend un ça c'est
typiquement le genre de position qui
peuvent très mal tourner
menace sous français 5 menaces d'AMF 6
fois 6
qualités de moins mais mes gros jeux
évidemment c'est pas G5 ça c'est un mix
clic donc C4
après Dame des C7 est possible des 5
quand même des fous prend un dame prend
j'y crois pas trop pour Maxime mais
peut-être qu'à valider 4 cavaler prend
des quatre fous prends des quatre tourbé
1 je préfère y jouer ça avec les Blancs
je vais pas vous mentir mais peut-être
ça va
il fait ces quatre ouais jamais tu
prends la cale on nous dit dans le chat
ouais je pense je pense pas non plus
c'est beaucoup trop dangereux de prendre
cette qualité
mais tu vas grandement tuer
donc il a fait ces quatre et des 5
comme prévu à janvier de dire il a pas
pris la qualité comme prévu séviant le
fout des deux c'est un coup en trop pour
avoir un temps de plus avoir le fond E3
qui interdisait cavaler des quatre
il fait tout simple
décalage alors là c'est aussi un faux
ami ça revient un peu sur le cours de
cette Mazet hier soir cavalier prend E2
c'est pas forcément la bonne idée parce
que les blancs les on les pions sur
casse blanche on n'a pas forcément envie
de prendre le fou ici même si on
pourrait continuer par B5 essayer de
tout faire péter mais normalement c'est
pas trop l'idée et tours c'est un c'est
un coup en fait enfin une double profil
accident il s'enlève de la diagonale
quand même parce qu'un jour ou l'autre
il aurait pu se faire manger et aussi
après ed il veut faire céder vous voyez
mais déjà un vis-à-vis entre la tour et
la dame c'est pour ça qu'il est parti
sur C1 et sur les idées comme B5 quand
il prendra la tour tapera sur sur C5
j'aurais horreur de jouer cette position
avec les Noirs je serai incapable de
jouer un coup Maxime qui fait B6 genre
un truc aussi bête que cavalier prend
alors CD j'y crois pas du tout le pion
est trop bizarre fout prend fou ces
trois disons E5 pour se fixer
vous prend des quatre peut-être
maintenant céder et F4 me terrorise ce
ce trident de pion me
donne la chair de poule il a vraiment
envie d'aller chercher le top 8 à
Toronto pour la grande finale avec les
200000 dollars c'est quand même pas rien
cette somme de 200000 dollars juste pour
les mettre en perspective
sur tout le circuit du Grand chastours
donc dans lequel les joueurs jouent
quatre tournois à la suite des quatre
tournois en remportant le circuit et en
faisant des résultats exceptionnels à
lire et zafiruja a pris la somme de 270
000 dollars
et donc il a joué quatre tournois pour
ça et la très très bien performé au
cours de ces quatre compétitions ici sur
sur cette compétition internet il faut
gagner 5 4 matchs pour pour arriver dans
la phase finale allez jouer quatre jours
en réel 5 jours en réel derrière et il y
a 200000 dollars à la clé donc c'est
quand même une somme très conséquente
pour les échecs pour aussi peu de jours
entre guillemets de compétition c'est
c'est le quart de ce que demande un
grand chef tour et ça rapporte quasiment
autant et donc la variante qui qui
arrivait dans la partie c'est celle dont
je vous parlais et ouais la position est
dure ça pour moi le problème c'est ce
pion dessin que je trouve un supportable
juste pour vous illustrer il faut
prendre pour prendre puis on prend
disons et c'est prend regardez ça
comment ça avance et comparer avec les
pions noirs j'espère que vous ressentez
le truc mais en fait ça va très très
vite côté blanc et c'est très difficile
à mettre en mouvement côté noir et quand
bien même ça avance
c'est beaucoup moins grave parce que
côté blanc ça avance proche du roi donc
F4 5 on peut même penser après à F5 ou
E6 ou D6 c'est bon après F4 5D 6 fois F3
ça paraît tentaculaire Maxime qui a fait
prendre des 5 directement
Sam qui va reprendre du pion c'est
attention à la partie dangereuse
en Maxime qui m'est peut-être des pièges
vous prend des quatre peu donner envie
aussi
mais il veut une prise en E4 le Fou est
cloué et sur un coup comme foue 5 il y a
pas tout reprendre
ces 7 mais l'idée de Maxime c'est Dame
E7 qui maintient l'attaque du Fou et
attaque la dame oh là là c'est ça le ça
très difficile à voir le dame 7 de
Maxime ça c'est un gros gros piège de
Maxime qu'est-ce que c'est marlou
il a joué ses prends des seins qu'il a
vu le dame 7 prix C3 prise C3
et là pour moi la position blanche c'est
une position de rêve Maxime encore une
nouvelle fois en difficulté sur sa
greenfeld
on se rappelle qu'il avait aussi perdu
lors de du
Grand Prix feed contre contre rapporte
avec les Noirs Maxime plus aussi serein
qu'avant sur sur la greenfeld mais voilà
est venu la période covid est venu alpha
zero qui a vraiment rebattu les cartes
de cette ouverture Maxime qui veut un
bloquer
mécaniquement le coût F4 mais là il va
se faire enchaîner par du tout trois par
du G3 par du F4 ça va être ça va être
très très difficile
Maxime qui sait qu'il est mal ça me
séviant qui a une chance de revenir dans
dans la partie dans la rencontre et ce
coup ça a l'air d'être tout droit pour
protéger le pion à G3 F4 5D 6
cette majorité là d'options c'est deux
pions magnifiques et on voit un même si
Maxime réussissait regardez le nombre de
coups qu'il faudrait pour réussir à
apporter le danger côté noir 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 coups pour réussir à peine créer un
semblant de danger alors que ça va être
1 2 3
et dès le 4ème coup de poussée de pion
les blancs réussiront à créer des
menaces violentes sur le roi donc
clairement maxime a un énorme retard
avec sa majorité de pions qu'on pourrait
appeler de silencieuse et là en plus ça
me peut juste commencer envoyer le Punto
en E5 la partie est très difficile
Maxime veut 5 tours 8 G3 Dame des 4 il
veut embrouiller Maxime 5 40%, c'est
bien et ce qui va avoir le temps de
terminer le français dames C2 allez tour
8 il faut vraiment réussir à à le
bloquer ce pion
allez ces choses faites et mettre une
dame en E5 peut-être c'est bien on va
avoir un plan comme tour de un fou F1 G3
F4 pour venir consolider cet aile roi et
ensuite réussir à mettre cette marche
avant Maxime sur tourin qui va mettre la
dame au 5 il commence par G3 alors
est-ce qu'il va sacrifier le pion H3
afin de se mettre en mouvement Sam alors
il le laisse complètement emprise mais
il veut faire 5 avancer Maxime qui le
prend à Maxime si tu lui donnes un punto
c'est toujours pris un Maxime si c'est
pas pourquoi c'est pas comestible il
bouffe et il voit après et là sur G4 il
doit avoir une idée farfelue
alors est-ce que ces dames prend F4 ou
est-ce que c'est plutôt peut-être damser
5 qui vient clouer la tourelle et ça lui
donnera le temps de H5 C4 c'est très
bien joué
Maxime qui est en train de faire ça
tambouille peut-être qu'il faut aller le
prendre ce pion C4 pour lui tu auras C8
Dame des 4 essayer de combler les cases
noires attention quand même e5d6 mais
Maxime veut essayer de faire un gros
blocus sur casse blanche et il y a un
peu moins de G4 F5 dans le range
Maxime qui a mis les barbelés la dame
qui va venir en D4 impérial
et là alors dis à une idée de marlou
l'ordi veut tourser de pour G4 tours 2
tours prend deux pour prendre G4 oh mais
c'est trop Maxime qui l'a évidemment il
a tous les coups Maxime et c'est pour ça
qu'il est si dur à battre dans danser
greenfeld
même si la position est dure Maxime qui
tente
qui trouve toutes les ressources
dynamiques tous les pièges mais aussi
cinq attention quand même hein ça avance
fort
le fou qui va pouvoir venir en F3
Maxime qui a peut-être tenté fougère
la connexion entre le fou et la dame
attention à la position reste quand même
très compromise côté français malgré le
gros enchaînement il part de très loin
dans cette partie F3 qui est jouée on
doit pas avoir de dames F5 à cause de
fous 4 fous prends ces deux et cette
tour en C2 est font H3 qui semble
quasiment combiné mais qui manque un
tout petit peu de punch pour le moment
pion j'ai trois défendus cette deuxième
rangée qui est juste assez défendue et
attention parce que ça peut parler fort
avec Dieu si ce qui peut partir côté
Samuel
attention
Maxime de pas se prendre aussi si la
dame venait à quitter cette diagonale en
G4 qui peut peut-être un jour enfermer
le fou ça peut être dangereux et on le
sent on le sent chaud patate il est
concentré il est dans la cage il veut
frelonner Maxime là
si il y a beaucoup de choses là pour
pour Samuel allez Maxime il faut qu'il
fasse le taf ou 4 pour ton repas de
suivi de Sion prend aussi il faut
prendre G6 ça peut s'enchaîner sur le
roi de Maxime
ça peut aller vite et fort mais il aura
encore tout fuites puis on prend aussi
dame prend des quatre tu reprends des
quatre ce serait dur à cette finale mais
il y a peut-être un tour F1 maths Marie
miraculeux à la fin allez je vais
essayer de la montrer la variante elle
est calculée à la main mais non il y a
pas de Tours F2 en fait il y a un punto
ici simplement
je prends mes rêves pour pour des
réalités il y a un punto en F4 mais il y
a peut-être du Tour C8 en décalage pour
Maxime pour aller chercher du Tour
tourner un tour C2 c'est peut-être ça
l'idée de Maxime oh non il y a fou
français de désolé mais il y a même fou
et 4 on prend nos rêves pour des
réalités peut-être fouger 4 allez
essayer de tenir ça
7 et sur F5 peut-être 7 x 6 la tour qui
débarquerait en C2 pour aller jouer le
perpète c'est ça les idées de Maxime les
idées de défense
ça me sévitant qui envoie aussi son va
probablement voir cette variante sur les
chiquer le fou qui arrivent en E4 qui
débarque le pion à deux qui va tomber et
c'est le pionger 6 qui va lui aussi
disparaître de l'échiquier et le pion
aussi se met Maxime qui va
contre-attaquer le long de la deuxième
et le long de la colonne C attention
attention Maxime il va falloir trouver
les bons coups mettre les barbelés ça me
séviant qui sait laisser un matelas
suffisant pour la terminer de 48 avec
les deux secondes par coup ça pourrait
suffire pour aller au bout attention oh
là Maxime faut qu'il nous trouve des
idées dont il a le secret son roi est
tellement en train de crier famine
et on n'arrive pas à connecter un tour
G2 ça suffit pas ça prend à deux ça va
prendre G6 côté Samuel
ça y est il va jouer on voit il a la
main sur la souris on le sent il fait un
décalage allez trompe toi trompe toi Sam
peut-être Maxime qui peut direct partir
en C8 au oui ça c'est pas une mauvaise
idée on y avait pas pensé à cette
tourelle en C8
et oui il y a plus pion prend dame prend
tout reprend il y a tourcé un match
direct c'est bien joué mais alors il y a
du dame F 600 oh dame F6
ça a l'air méchant quand même il a l'air
méchant Samuel mais plus de 16 allée
Maxime
il n'y a pas de gain imminent ça
menacera pas puis on prend aussi ça sera
ça va être à mon avis soit dame 5 pour
aller d'un match 5 dame G5 soit dame F6
pour s'approcher de la case F7 il y a
pas de gain direct pour Sam c'est bien
et il est en train de se laisser avec 40
secondes oh il peut même la perdre Sam
ça va être du 50/50 cette partie
il fait tout 5 il choque complètement en
fait oh il choque pas quand même ça
reste chaud mais il s'est laissé que 40
secondes Maxime qui va fermer la porte
attention F5 fou prend pion prend
peut-être du des 6 tours c'est de Maxime
qui a trois vins
il a assez de temps là Maxime pour
réussir à trouver un piège on le voit là
il a affûté oh il a fuité le garçon il a
affûté le Maxime donc l'ordinateur comme
meilleur coup avec position égale mais
c'est pas forcément sale coup qu'on
cherche tourgé deux avant roi H1 tu
reprends G3 tours géants ou bien jouer
de la part de séviant il Adam prend
géant au jouet tempo quelle réponse du
joueur américain qui trouve une variante
incroyable il avait prévu il avait prévu
le piège de Maxime c'était son coup mais
il en fait
défense impressionnante ici du joueur
américain qui retourne la situation la
dame en géante qui va être magnifique
pour lui elle va taper le roi elle va
tout couvrir pour prendre géant d'arme
prends géant dame j'ai 7 ton G5
peut-être ouais F8 mais c'est dur il va
y avoir du fouet 5 du fulpro H3 Maxime
non dans la difficulté là là ça me
séviant qui qui enchaîne quelques coups
de boutoir 44 secondes
c'est juste mais ça peut suffire
et lorsque la dame arrive en géant ça
menacera une découverte en haut 8 avec
un fou 8 échecs vous prend des sets qui
pourra arriver c'est tomber quand même
pile-poil pour ça mais là qui a eu un
petit peu de réussite c'est mérité quand
même côté ça me séviance ce petit coup
de pouce du destin
H4 ça paraîtra un bon coup attention la
tour G5 on l'a tourgé 5 qui peut faire
très mal pour ranger 5 tu en prends G5
tours c'est un roi H2 bon pour G5 qui a
l'air de tuer la partie simplement et ce
qui va l'avoir c'est bien ou pas allez
27 secondes il est dans le dur il a pas
pour le moment attends j'ai 5 et
monumental en fait ouais F8 cADAM H8 et
il l'a ouais c'est dur pour Maxime
évidemment tours pas papillon prend qui
bloque la colonne mais bien tout reprend
tour c'est un échec roche 2 et il y a
même pas de Tours C2 Maxime qui est en
train de se faire éteindre et pourtant
on en est pas encore au pénurie
d'énergie mais là ça me séviant qui a
qui a décidé de couper le gaz de Maxime
sous le pied avant l'hiver allez il faut
encore trouver un piège côté Maximo 5
c'est un joli coup mais ça doit perdre
de plusieurs manières possibles
mais c'est marlou ça fait suer
fu F5 échecs
Maxime va décaler le roi il a pas 10 000
cases il va pas il peut pas aller en
fuite il y a peut-être juste dame P4
dont j'ai 8 et dame prend le 7 qui
suffit mais il y a plus que 9 secondes
c'est bien qui hésitent il fait dame B4
ça va être dame 7 pour Maxime tourgé 8 3
projet 8 et dame prend E7 eh oui les
tourelles sont ceux des doubles il
réfléchit à quoi Sam plus que trois
secondes il va tomber non il a réussi à
jouer Maxime qui va faire peut-être ton
projet 8 t'en prends j'ai 8 dames prends
E7 et sur fuprint F5 il y aura dame G5
dame pro F5 5 secondes 2 avec 2 secondes
par coup ça va largement suffire à
Samuel pour égaliser dans ce match un
partout quelle réponse du joueur
américain partie rondement mener et
Maxime une nouvelle fois en difficulté
alors il a peut-être un piège c'est roi
prend ton repenser trois puis on prend
d’âme prend le 7 tours c'est un match
c'est peut-être le seul mais c'est bien
maigre
Maxime qui abandonne j'aurais peut-être
tenté à sa place c'est ton jamais
ça aurait pu quand même tenter mais
Maxime qui a décidé d'abandonner et à la
surprise générale ça me sévion qui
égalise dans ce match un point partout
ça pour une surprise c'est une surprise
il avait fait pousser cinq ou trois il a
dû analyser Sam c'est bien entre les
parties
ok j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont tous les
deux regarder entre
à connaître c'est pas très bien quand ça
connaît loin c'est pas bon signe
c'est terrible il a dû regarder la main
il a tous les coups c'est bien en fait
il y a pas tout reprendre des 4 c'est
important de comprendre à cause de dame
prend des cartes d'âme prend des 4
cavalue deux donc ça c'est extrêmement
con un important de l'avoir et c'est sûr
vu la vitesse à laquelle il joue et vu
la première partie c'est sûr que c'est
bien entre les parties la regarder
jusque là ah ouais non là c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle c'est bien c'est pas cool
là qu'il est pris le dessus dans
l'ouverture
parce que je pense que le problème de
Maxime a réglé dans la grumefell est
plus difficile nulle rapide voilà non
non là c'est c'est loin d'être nul
rapide les échecs en cadence rapide
justement cette position là elle joue
hein mais il était tellement bien à la
sortie de l'ouverture dans la première
partie qu'on aurait pu espérer qu'il
réussisse ça à mettre la tête sous l'eau
de séviant
et malheureusement il a pas réussi il a
fait tour à 7 ouais
je de tempo de Maxime alors rage de
l'idée c'est que maintenant il menace
pour prendre des quatre
et sur tour D7 il doit avoir une idée de
marlou il leur dit propose des trois
des trois qui est ultra malin mais dur
voilà [ __ ] c'est hyper dur en fait tu
veux j'ai trois Dame des quatre leur dit
[ __ ] c'est hyper dur et c'est même pas
clair parce qu'il y a dame F3 et bon
c'est hyper dur surtout très risqué
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de choses qui
sont ratables cavaliers aussi ouais ben
là c'est en train de tourner pour Maxime
en fait parce que le roi noir il est
plus faible et le pion des 4 il n'est
pas vraiment de marche avant
bonne question
en fait si tu veux en H1 tu menaces pas
H3 j'ai 3 pardon
c'est protéger le pion
dommage 5 pour Maxime sur cavalier G5 il
doit avoir une idée
ça joue vraiment bien ah il doit juste
vouloir foudre ou H4
le niveau de jeu est très très velu et
surgit six vous prend cavalier F4 il a
dame 5
de passer une énorme séance
assez viandes
6 3 G1 G6 avec des fous prangés 6
cavalie F4 il y a plus d'âme 5
ah ouais c'est beau les échecs quand
c'est comme ça pas de G6 direct parce
que dame 5 en fait c'est Dame 5 échec
ouais
le problème d'un F6
[Musique]
ça c'est dur et du coup c'est chèque en
premier pour faire G6 et 4 le dame 5 et
sur foopranger 6 cavaliers F4
c'est jouer par Sam c'est bien ah ouais
c'est c'est costaud donc là pour le
moment le roi blanc est en échec c'est
pour ça qu'on peut pas faire maintenant
j'ai trois G6 et sur un et surtout
ranger 6 là dessus c'était cavalier F4
quand même je suppose et le problème
c'est que sur pion prend dame prend il y
a la tour en des deux qui en l'air pour
vous expliquer tous les tous les
problèmes de la position Dame des 5
l'idée c'est Dame prend fou prends
touche le cavalier on pourra peut-être
prendre des quatre
façons il a pas pris il a fait il a fait
tourner 7 qui est plus logique
il échange tout alors ça a cliqué vite
cette variante maintenant est-ce que on
peut prétendre à quelque chose roager 2
disons parce que c'est logique ça touche
la tour ça protège tour B3 tours
D3 je sais pas c'est ça reste ultra
complet maxime a fait tourcer 4
donc il va y avoir tourbé 3 c'est joué
par Sam
ça va bouffe de ouais non c'est nul ok
le pion qui va venir en D3 ok Maxime
veut jouer quand même un truc
intéressant ça doit pas pouvoir gagner
mais c'est intéressant niveau roi F3
tour des 4 enfin genre D3 ils ont ça ça
ça ça et ça et la tour est enfermée
très marlou
évidemment Sam c'est bien la vue il a
fait des trois rois G2
il a fait des trois il veut quoi il veut
roi F3
disons roi G7 3 E3
disons H5 tour des 4 tours
ça va être chaud
hyper intéressant une nouvelle fois
là pour le moment la tour a plus de 15
mais on n'a pas d'accès à cette tour
parce que en fait le seul accès qu'on a
c'est celui-là
est-ce que on peut y aller genre on
envoie un plan comme ça roi et fin REV1
roi des un roi lycéens roi B1 roi à deux
ça paraît long mais en fait tu fais quoi
avec les noirs
c'est une vraie question c'est pas une
blague
en fait c'est quoi c'est un deux trois
quatre cinq six coups ok tu fais roi F1
roi G7 roi E1 roi F6 roi D1 disons H5
roi C1 tour eiffe roi B1 tours 2 et
encore un ça joue prise prise tout
recâtre tu vas quand même avoir un pion
plus mais ça doit être nul mais ça veut
dire que roi F1 c'est pas une tentative
débile pas proposé par l'ordi mais loin
d'être stupide il fait tout recap Maxime
je suis en train de réfléchir à Tours
c'est 6 ici
si tu prends des deux je prends B3 si tu
prends des trois je prends C2
ouais non c'est c'est trop en fait
mais après ça ça doit quand même rester
nul mais c'est pion de plus d'ailleurs
tu peux avoir un plan comme roi F1 roi
E2 roi des un roi c'est un tour c'est à
5 tours on peut en porte on se on se
gare
c'est tellement dur à jouer parce qu'il
y a tellement d'options
pour 7 je pense qu'il va partir en H6
mais Maxime va tenter de le réseauter
mais je pense qu'il va partir en H6 et
qui va essayer de partir quand même pour
un ah ouais
je pense 3 H6 c'est un bon coup ici pour
séviant après attention parce que roi H6
F4 tu reprends B2 tu reprends B2 D2 il y
a G4
infernal D1 il y a j'ai 5 rois H5 tu
reprends H7 donc ça veut dire que tu
peux mettre cette menace oh qu'est-ce
que c'est dur du coup il a fait rouager
8 le level des deux joueurs est assez
impressionnant est-ce que sur un coup
comme j'ai pas H4 est-ce que tu reprends
B2 fait nul en force ici
j'ai l'impression
pas sur
ça c'est nul en force et pas trop dur à
faire
Maxime qui a fait H4 et là il a tout
reprend B2 et c'est nul en force ces
pions plus pour Maxime mais c'est une
nul facile Maxime qui met la pression
mais mais qui réussir pas à faire rompre
Sam séviant pour le moment qui nous
targue d'un beau spectacle ouais
dans la salle à jouer ultra fort alors
moi je calculé variantes mais je peux
les checks à l'ordi ils ont pas le temps
de chèque à l'ordi donc leur vitesse de
calcul est hallucinante c'est la
différence entre 2008 chez som et 3100
j'ai réussi à suivre ce qu'ils font
uniquement parce que j'ai l'air de la
turbinette en fait sinon c'est ça va
trop vite en fait
c'est beaucoup trop grande
on peut pas capitaliser sur tôle c'était
pas possible ok il veut faire wash 6 et
G4 G5 mais c'est vu par Sam c'est bien
il va essayer de monter le roi Maxime
ça faire tourner à 4 tours B3 et je
pense qu'il va faire tout à 7 ici au roi
G7 H5 professionnel ouais c'est bien
joué
c'est bien qui est en retard à
l'allumage et Maxime c'est dommage en
cette deuxième partie je vous avais dit
attention c'est pas le même niveau que
il tourid Zaga les baisses de régime
peuvent coûter très cher face à un
joueur du calibre de samsevian et ça a
pas manqué il a tout de suite égalisé
derrière il a serré avec les noirs très
bien joué de sa part c'est entre 1 et 5
choses 3100
mais il pourrait 3100 si faisait du full
try hard et ouais c'est c'est la
différence ils sont ils sont ces joueurs
sont stratosphériques c'est une autre il
va mettre le rang H6 je pense bah c'est
bien joué
quand on a des belles parties je vous
comprends pas trop parfois dans le chat
genre moi je suis juste heureux de voir
deux belles parties de trois belles
parties d'échecs jusqu'à maintenant je
trouve ça extrêmement agréable à suivre
je trouve c'est parti très très agréable
à regarder quand les deux hommes se
répondent coup pour coup pour coup
un Maxime qui essaie de tourner mais ça
c'est nul il va essayer de mettre le
rangée 5 et d'une manière X ou Y mais il
pourra pas
ça me solide sur ses appuis et Maxime
qui va être en danger il va avoir les
Noirs dans la quatrième
ça va être très chaud
Maxime qui tente qui essaie de faire
chier jusqu'au bout
c'est bien ce qui fait Maxime
c'est égalita la quatrième armag est
donc je crois que c'est direct mais
allez
est-ce que ça peut craquer côté séviants
non je crois pas
elle te reprend h4f6
mes tours F4 aurait fait toi-même tu
repars facile parce que en fait contre
le pion G on peut faire la défense
passive
ouais
danger pour Maxime qui a l'air déçu à la
caméra bon allez let's go arrêtons de
parler des subs de twitch on en a plus
rien à [ __ ] allez let's go allez
Maxime ouais ça là il faut qu'il
s'accroche on va de mettre l'échiquier
de l'autre côté pour être en phase avec
le design moi je suis inquiet
je suis pas serein ok il a révisé Maxime
il a révisé parce que tout à l'heure on
avait vu qu'il fallait mieux mettre le
damassin sur échec allez c'est bien il
rend le coup du berger à la bergère
mais c'est bien ça ouais il veut
cavalier prend pris un prison et jouer
sur le foie 6
faut qu'il se rappelle Maxime faut
absolument qu'il se rappelle
il faut absolument qu'il se rappelle
alors qu'elle prend F3 bon alors les
enjeux de la position pour c'est trop
compliqué en fait à expliquer il y a pas
d'enjeu en fait c'est que tactique on va
te les échecs il y a des fois ça
s'explique des fois ça s'explique pas et
là en gros on menace fubéca de fou prend
le 7 d'un côté
donc qui fait cavalier D3 prise D3
fougères 5 bon il connaît encore Maxime
je suis rassuré il menace tour prend B7
et fou prend le 7 et la ligne d'après
ordi ça semblait Tour Eiffel 8 tours B7
fous B5 enferme le la Tour Eiffel vous
prend B7 tour eb8 et il va récupérer en
fulo
bon c'est connu par Maxime allez c'est
cool vous pouvez être ça rentre c'est
c'est la ligne alors après est-ce que
c'est tout rabb8 tour à 8 est-ce que
c'est ton eb8 ça j'en sais rien mais ça
passe leur dit propose de commencer
parfois si éventuellement bon il y a
plusieurs options mais l'important à
retenir là dedans c'est que Maxime s'est
rappelé loin de la théorie là on est
encore dans la prépa on est au 20e coup
Maxime se met peut-être à réfléchir mais
il sait que c'est égal donc on est on
est rassuré et je crois que derrière
c'est un Armageddon c'est pas le mort
subite et l'Armageddon me fait suer
d'avance voilà ça peut faire turbodro
hein l'Armageddon fait Sud d'avance bon
là maxime a réussi à se rappeler et à
réussir à fermer la porte
je sais pas s'il vaut mieux qu'on soit
au blanc au noir je sais pas si on s'est
mis en Robin un violon qui a une donnée
la règle exacte mémorit test oui enfin
mémorith
réussit ça va faire 5 contre 3 pions sur
la même aile il va faire fuite
c'est la variante que j'ai montré juste
avant théorie
c'est la théorie jusque là en fait donc
il faut prendre f3.8 5 tours à 8 en fait
ça c'est ouais mais la finale je pense
pas qu'elle soit après sable je voudrais
qu'il soit rappelé à proprement parler
de la théorie jusqu'au bout mais juste
il a retrouvé à la main quoi alors
attendez il y a une question quand même
vous prenez fui trois points F8
cavaliers G5 H6 cavalier.f7 tu reprends
le 4 ouais ok et les tourterelles
s'activent et ça peut carrément être
dangereux pour les blancs ici ok c'est
enchères oh [ __ ] c'est en chair c'est
Armageddon enchères oh le malaise
termine par une égalité une seule partie
rapidement
15 minutes et doivent gagner avec un
système d'enchères pour déterminer qui
allait noir alors Maxime il a quoi comme
strat joue plus vite que c'est Vian
Maxime va dire 10 minutes je pense
cher caché comme pour la pour la Ligue 1
au foot pour l'armée dans le système
d'enchères c'est le plus juste ça met
les deux joueurs sur un pied d'égalité
avant la partie c'est très cool comme
système les enchères parce que
l'Armageddon les Noirs gagnent en cas de
nul
donc moins de temps mieux c'est mais je
pense que Maxime ouais va dire 10
minutes ça doit lui suffire si c'est
bien dit neuf il va lui mettre tellement
le bouillon à la pendule
que ça va suer
mais c'est bien on va pas dire 9 ah non
on a émis 6 minutes 6 minutes c'est
dangereux quand même c'est il s'est
réellement
trop relâché attention ça ça peut être
ici
V4 c'est dur à savoir
dépend des rajouts des machins c'est
compliqué
autant de chaises comme n'a pu nous
habituer par le passé avec des formats
un peu bizarre et un peu relou à suivre
autant là il faut dire que c'est pas le
cas
c'est un format agréable
on va réussir à faire les deux pions
passés liés mais c'est juste nul après
il va se faire
ah non tu essayes quand même un peu avec
les Blancs
vous allez voir
là ça va répéter ouais comme je vous
disais hein c'est les positions qui ont
aucun intérêt je vous mets pas j'aime
pas vous mettre de suspense quand il y
en a pas Maxime 11 minutes ok je pensais
qu'il prendrait 10 mais il a dû
comprendre que c'est bien prendrait pas
moins allez c'est parti Maxime avec les
Noirs qu'est-ce qui va nous faire c'est
quoi trop ah c'est bien pourquoi il y a
15 minutes ok il y a 11 minutes pour
Maxime ça part c'est quoi trop ça
réfléchi Maxime qui doit se demander sur
cavalier M6 qu'est-ce qu'il veut et
Maxime qui fait 5 allez joli décalage de
Maxime qui qui sait que Sam séviant à
une idée derrière la tête et il joue ses
6 alors
il y a la variante avec des 4 cartes qui
peut éventuellement ressembler à de la
française bizarre de loin il y a
cavalier F3 E4 cavalier D4 qui est un
genre dalapine avec un temps de moins
donc là on est vraiment dans une à
lapine à couleur inversée où il y aurait
eu le G6 en plus
dame prend E3 dame 5 ouais ça c'est une
grosse variante là actuellement il y a
eu quelques parties là dessus
et Maxime qui a réussi à décaler dans
l'ouverture c'est bon il est il a réussi
à éviter la prépa et ce qui connaît bien
la position
j'imagine que oui je pense que fearuja
peut avoir ça dans son répertoire et on
sait que Maxime fait des Blitz
d'entraînement avec Ali resa
et là voilà très bonne nouvelle c'est
que ça me sévit on commence déjà à
prendre dans son temps alors si vous de
vous demander pourquoi maxime n'a plus
de 10 minutes 45 c'est très simple au
début de la partie Samse vient avec 15
minutes maximum à 10 mois avec 11
minutes si j'ai les Noirs je peux faire
nul et me qualifier ça me séduit en
avait proposé 12 minutes 30 maxi m'a
remporté l'enchère et donc Maxime un
retard autant handicap mais il a
l'avantage que nul lui permet de gagner
la partie après l'actuellement on a une
position assez tendue on voit que la
structure est complètement asymétrique
ici avec ce pion E4 qui avançait sur
l'échiquier donc évidemment on est
content d'avoir pris de l'espace côté
noir mais on voit que les blancs sont
prêts à rebondir il y a déjà deux pièces
qui tapent sur le pion il y a ce
cavalier qui peut revenir en E3 il y a
le pion des trois qui peut le
débouchaîner mais derrière il y aura
encore le petit muret B7 C6 position
compliquée ici un coup comme cavalier A6
et thématique pour revenir vers ces cinq
moi j'ai envie de dire ouais pour le
moment où il a fait faux sept meilleur
Sky ici ce qui a été 5 et aussi possible
j'ai envie de dire après rock peut-être
Maxime rock rapidement et on verra après
attention aussi au plan cavaliers 3
dames C2 et donc là peut-être cavalier à
6 peut être pas mal d'âme C2 cavalier
c'est 5 mais B4 il faut regarder ces
choses-là on peut aussi passer par des 7
mais cavaliers à 6 dames C2 il y a aussi
cavalier B4 dam B1 il y a beaucoup
d'options il faut juste être méfiant de
pas aller se faire encaisser le Punto
parce que dams et de cavalier prend en
quatre c'est deux coups et ça gagne le
pion donc cavalier à 6 dames C2 il
faudra il faut y réfléchir est-ce que
cavalier c'est 5 B4
c'est un problème ou pas la question est
posée moi je pose des questions je vais
pas y répondre après une fois que le
pion est en B4 c'est cloué mais le temps
de côté quand il fait damser de fou B2
ça ça met un vis-à-vis dans la dame
position difficile 930 9 30 pour Maxime
on n'a pas les pendules du bon côté il
faut qu'on se mette côté blanc désolé
on est on est à l'envers on est à
l'envers c'est trop l'habitude de mettre
de côté Maxime ça ça inverse le truc
mais bon vous avez bien compris que
Maxime a les noirs de toute façon
ok B4 jouer l'idée de séviance c'est
quoi c'est fou B2 dame C2 et taper E4
tour 8 il va faire fou B2
Maxime qui a réussi à tenir le pion mais
attention on a ce cavalier en 6 qui est
qui est loin du jeu on a Sion E4 qui est
fragile on a du mal à toucher le
cavalier genre pour illustrer disons que
les Blancs joue dame C2 on va mettre le
fond fit on a du mal à toucher le
cavalier pour mettre le pion F5 du coup
Maxime va probablement partir pour un
plan de type cavalier c'est ça qui a
validé 5 pour replacer ce cavalier et
essayer de prendre le cavalier c'est
trois peut-être pour abaisser la
pression sur le pion E4 donc on va voir
est-ce qu'il va mettre la dame en C2
fouet fuite et il peut peut-être tenter
de jouer avec du cavalier A4 pour
essayer de toucher la case C5
il y a beaucoup de pièces sur
l'échiquier Maxime qui est revenu au
temps ça c'est la bonne nouvelle onze
minutes 20 contre 9-03
Maxime qui est bien autant quand même il
revient fort et pour le moment c'est
viande trouve pas vraiment la clé dans
cette position dame ces deux fois fuites
ça c'est sûr vous décises alors très
étonnant pour moi un coup comme
foodécisme parce qu'on dit souvent que
le fouet est bien placé en fuite un
proche du roi il défend le roi et il
gêne pas sur les colonnes et en venant
des 6 en plus il tape sur la case G3
mais à mon avis ce donc sur du solide
mais à mon avis ça peut être expliqué
par le fait qu'il veut jouer fou à E5
Maxime et venir jouer cahier des cinq
fouets 5 et vraiment liquider le
matériel s'il y arrive évidemment c'est
fort là pour avoir votre information
l'ordinateur propose comme seule manière
de jouer pour l'avantage un truc très
difficile des trois pions on prend qui
sera à mon avis pas joué parce que ça
pourrit la structure mais ok on peut
comprendre le jeu pour du cavalier C4
jouer sur le fouet etc mais ça parait
trop difficile il y a quand même
cavalière à 4 en option parce que sur B6
il y a dames français 6 ah il y aurait
peut-être fou des sept dames c'est de
bon avoir mes cavaliers A4 est une
option c'est sûr ça se regarde
F3 en est une autre alors il veut pion
prend
et il veut prendre à mon avis de la tour
ouais alors ces positions là il y a un
enjeu
incroyable c'est est-ce que les Blancs
réussissent à faire le 4 des 4 en gros
si c'est bien on met les pions E4 et des
4 il est mieux en fait ça va faire un
rouleau compresseur à terre il va enfin
il va réussir à mettre la marche avant
il va faire mal par contre s'il y arrive
pas ça va aller ce qui me déplaît ici
dans la position de Maxime c'est qu'il y
a une menace hyper forte pour les blancs
c'est cavaliers F5 D4 E4 E5 en fait si
séviant réussit enchaîner ces trois
coups sévion est mieux et ce fou en E5
de Maxime me déplaît fortement parce
qu'il est venu Maxime en fait il est
bien placé son fou mais il est dans le
trafic c'est à dire que regarder si les
blancs réussissent à faire cavalier F5
D4 je touche le fou le four parent des 6
E4 donc imaginez les deux pions E4 D4 je
menacerai déjà E5 fourchettes j'espère
que vous l'avez dans le chat c'est une
menace forte dans la position on peut
pas se permettre de jouer j'ai ici c'est
trop dégueulasse la F les Blancs ont
déjà mis lors de tour dessus et le fou
B2 il tape sur F6 donc ça c'est un
énorme problème le long de la colon F
et la menace de la position elle est
simple cavalier D5 à pas l'air d'être
une option à cause de cavalier prend et
j'imagine qu'il y a un problème un jour
sur le pion F7 qui paraît assez faible
je dirais pour le moment que l'ouverture
est ratée côté Maxime Le Fou des 6 x 5 a
été réfuté par le plan de séviants
d'ouvrir la colonne F et d'aller taper
sur F5 maxime est en danger dans ce
16ème de finale du Global cheesecom
Championship 2022 avec je le rappelle
plus d'un million de dollars de prix
200000 dollars au vainqueur du tournoi
donc une coquette somme à gagner et pour
le moment c'est séviant qui dans
l'ouverture à la surprise générale on
sentait que Maxime était pas mal sorti
et là un petit coup à côté le fou des 6
et la position de Maxime est
immédiatement compliqué on nous propose
dans le chat un coup comme fout des
quatre
qui peut être intéressant mais fous des
quatre j'ai peur juste de roi H1
décalage puis cavaliers F5 quand même
puis E3 puis des 4 puis 4 puis 5 ça
avance fort Maxime en danger ici Maxime
qui prend son temps au bon moment j'ai
envie de dire mais peut-être un coup
trop tard c'est peut-être le fou des 6
qui est parti trop vite
ça traduit ça traduit une difficulté
dans la position on a compris le l'enjeu
et on comprend le problème cavalier F5
des 4 4 qui peut partir à une vitesse
grand V le fou qui va être moche tout va
être moche
il est en train de réfléchir si un G6 se
passe à mon avis pour essayer
d'interdire cavalier F5 mais ça doit
être peine perdue
A4 faut prendre B2 dame prend B2 le kick
arrive en C5 le cavalier F6 qui qui
semble battre de l'aile
la paix et taper fort cavaler ces quatre
peut-être Maxime veut fouger 4 mais il y
aura tout trois foot et quatre allez
c'est ça l'idée de Maxime il veut
cavaler ses quatre fous j'ai quatre il y
a pas de Tours 3 à cause de fous des
quatre mais il y a peut-être cavalier
prend le 5 intermédiaire et on n'a pas
de [ __ ] en F3 à cause de cavalier
prend ouais ça peut ça peut être dur
ça peut être difficile ça peut être
difficile
cavalier c'est quoi trop on peut pas
sauver ce fou et sur fout des quatre
échec direct E3 fouger 4 ne passe pas il
y a encore puis on prend des quatre et
on reprend F3 aucun va laisser 4 à l'air
vraiment fort alors l'ordi donne
cavalier C4 cavaliers F5 comme deux
coups équivalents mais d'un point de vue
pratique je peux vous dire que cavalier
C4 fait mal parce qu'une fois que ce
fouet 5 il a disparu aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
le fou B2 qui va taper fort et dur bah
ouais celui-là il est il est en ligne
droite hein il est en ligne droite la
diagonale elle est bien levée là c'est
pas c'est pas du demi tapage sur sur la
diagonale et il fait cavalier F5 on
souffle un peu on souffle un peu côté
français c'est avantage c'est avantage
blanc oui mais à mon avis on soufflotte
quand même parce que le roi est quand
même moins faible alors ouais il va
vouloir jouer pour B5 il va vouloir nous
taper de l'autre côté mais bon c'est pas
le roi qui a attaqué c'est une partie un
peu plus que l'on court Maxime va avoir
le temps de revenir dedans il va avoir
le temps de revenir dans cette partie
fout des quatre échecs ça semble pas
être un coup il y a E3 peut-être Dame
des 7 un petit décalage de la dame
attention quand même oh ça peut
tellement rentrer de partout
je sais pas je commence à avoir des
cavaliers 4 il y a peut-être des tours
F7 qui marche dans certaines positions
Maxime qui a toujours 3 minutes de
retard qui arrive pas à se refaire là
c'est durable Dame des 7 jouets il y a
qu'un coup qui donne l'avantage pour les
blancs c'est un coup très logique mais
c'est E3 mais là ça peut tanker côté ça
me parce que cavalier 4 visuellement on
a envie de le regarder on n'arrive pas
trop à le faire marcher vous prend B2
dames prends B2 ca va les prendre
F7 trois points F7 c'est une petite
variante à l'emporte-pièce sûrement pas
la main mais passe pas donc il a le 3 il
va avoir le D4 il va avoir le 4 c'est le
scénario dont je vous parlais voilà
marche avant et mise là
le plan main est en train de prendre
forme là pour Sam je vous en ai parlé il
y a une dizaine de coups je vous ai dit
le plan des blancs ici c'est E4 D4 c'est
mettre les pions et avancer ce faire
avancer ce rouleau compresseur
et Maxime qui va tenter le blocus sur
casse blanche allez Maxime il faut
l'arrêter ce rouleau fous des 6
peut-être mettre le foin et fuite ok des
4 jouets fous des 6 ça va être joué je
vous ai dit ça c'est le plan principal
equattro maintenant qui va partir il va
falloir sur 5 essayer de faire un gros
blocus sur la case
sur la case D5 alors juste pour revenir
on pouvait pas faire de fou français 3
auparavant d'armes français 3 dames on
va se prendre cette batterie qui qui
clôture la la Game c'est je reviens très
rapidement là-dessus c'est une question
qui revenait donc il a réussi à faire le
D4 à faire le 4 et l'objectif dont je
vous parlais ici après F3 E3 F3 dame
prend F3 objectif stratégique à long
terme mettre les pions des quatre et E4
objectif qui a été réalisé par Samse
Vian qui prend le contrôle du centre et
qui menace maintenant E5 cavalu aussi
pour Maxime allez ça commence les
problèmes pour Sam 5 cavaliers prend des
quatre allez le marlou est de sortie le
marlou est de sortie cavalieux de sa
défend pour le moment ouais c'est bien
défendu ce centre assez dur là le centre
qui est complètement blindé par les
pièces mineures fous aussi alors là
est-ce qu'il y a pas e5ae 5 ca et 5 on
souffle tu reprends F7 cavaliers 3
on est zen on est encore là ça passe
encore pour le moment côté Maxime mais
on va aller on va pouvoir mettre un
barbelant F8 défendre le pion F7 coûte
que coûte et espérer que les Blancs
avancent un moment et créer le blocus
5,55338 j'ai l'impression qu'il y a pas
de rajout de temps allez si ça si on
rentre dans la minute après dans les
deux minutes là chacun
Maxime pourra faire parler sa pointe de
vitesse mais il va falloir y arriver il
va falloir survivre mais là c'est bien
ce que fait Maxime il a réussi à
garder une position difficile
parce que la poussée E5 semble pas
marcher à cause skyd5 qui fait damsé un
ou malin il veut E5 et des 5 tours F7 il
y a plus de cavaliers 3 Maxime qui fait
la tour à F8 ces choses faites et
maintenant attention peut-être un coup
comme dessin peut partir ça va lui
ouvrir le fou F2 ça peut être fort allez
faut que ça me sévion recentre le
souffle de Maxime là derrière ça nuque
il sait que Maxime c'est un des joueurs
les plus Marlo les plus malins ceux que
celui de ceux qui arnaque le mieux dans
le circuit
il faut que ça me sévi on ressente un
petit peu cette cette pression du requin
aux dents j'ai envie de dire aiguiser et
la tour qui est venue en E8 pour le
moment elle est poussée de pions sont
pas à son pas si folichonne
bien mis les barbeles
quand même ce centre donc on a pas
forcément envie même si ça doit garder
l'avantage pour les blancs et en
attendant et ça il le fait aller dessin
que ça part il rentre dans le combat
immédiat Sam il a raison il se garde du
temps le cavalier qui doit peut-être
venir en C7 il va peut-être ramener une
tour en G5 regardez regardez la batterie
la tour G5 tête H6 attention qui est pas
un tour projet 7 un jour attention
Maxime muscle ton jeu
muscle ton jeu Maxime
tour j'ai 5 H 6 et ce qui a [ __ ] F6
puis on prend G5 dames rangée 5 fous
prends F6 tours F6 les caméras qui ont
été décalées on va essayer de les
retrouver rapidement quand même c'est
trop important de réussir à avoir les
joueurs ici je peux pas ne pas ne pas
voir la bouille de Maxime allez c'est
récupéré la régie qui fait le travail
allez la tour peut-être en G5 h6 il y a
pas de il y a pas de chaos il y a pas de
chaos pour le moment heureusement oh il
y a peut-être ça oh le malaise
non leur dit tiens il y a dan D8
miraculeux
ça passe pas ça passe pas
et leur dit d'un tourgé 5 quand même sur
H6 Lordi à quelque chose
tu reprends G7 trois projets 7 et D6
c'est terrible c'est terrible c'est
terrible
dame prend des 6 c'est cavaliers des
quatre ça va pas être trouvé ça par Sam
ça c'est trop dur ça c'est trop dur
Maxime qui va faire à 6
allez ça a l'air de tenir pour le moment
ça a l'air de tenir pour Maxime
ah si là tu reprends G7 c'est terminé
mais ça me paraît introuvable ton
reponger ces trois points G7 D6 et
cavaliers des cartes c'est très dur ah
s'il a des six c'est terminé ça me
séviant qui a une balle de matchs ici
voici fait tout reprendre et cette D6 ça
tire la dame dame prends ici c'est
cavaliers des quatre s'en est fini de
désespoir de Maxime après ces cavaliers
F5 échecs dame prend H6 ça rentre comme
papa dans maman oh c'est le coup de la
partie sinon c'est ton GF5 et l'ordi
donne égal oh c'est maintenant les amis
oh là qu'est-ce que c'est beau ton
projet ces trois projets 7 et D6 ça a
été complètement raté par Maxime c'est
extrêmement dur il a il lent il l'a ça
me séviant oh c'est terrible Maxime qui
va disparaître du tableau éliminer
quasiment maintenant du Global chaises
comme champion'sheep ah ça sentait il y
avait du temps plongé 7 dans l'air et ça
a été trouvé par samsevian et Maxime qui
va prendre la porte dès ce deuxième tour
ouais c'est la correctionnelle là pour
le champion du monde de Blitz
c'est terrible ce que ce que Samuel
Sevian vient de viendrait réussir à
faire la position était difficile et
réussie à à faire sauter les cases
noires
Maxime qui aura peut-être fait un choix
discutable dans l'ouverture mais
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué de la part
de samsevian bon c'est trouvable à
arrêter dans le chat de raconter de la
merde c'est trop trouvable des escape
parce que tu regardes que ça et ça me
séviant qui trouve une magnifique
combinaison et c'est gagné ça me séviant
qui a sué mais qui est qualifié Maxime
qui se déconnecte immédiatement et donc
il n'y a plus de joueurs français dans
ce global cheescom Championship Maxime
qui pourra s'en vouloir non pas d'avoir
perdu cette Armageddon puisque
finalement
ça me séviant à réaliser une partie XXL
mais mais plutôt d'avoir eu ce
relâchement coupable dans la deuxième
partie qui a laissé Samuel Sevian
revenir dans le match et Maxime coup de
tonnerre éliminé du Global cheesecom
Championship le joueur américain qui
mérite sa qualification